We're almost
halfway through 2016,
or "the year of no chill"
as I've been calling it.
There are already so many
high-level things going on
that seem like maybe
they'll be a global catastrophe,
or maybe things will go okay.
We don't know.
We don't (bleep) know.
(laughter)
Uh, let's see.
There's a presidential election.
Could spell the end
of America as we know it,
or maybe it'll be fine.
We don't (bleep) know.
Is the environment
gonna be okay,
or will we all drown
in a super tsunami?
We don't (bleep) know.
Will the recent British vote
to leave the European Union
turn the UK
into an Orwellian nightmare?
-We don't (bleep) know!
-(laughter)
Maybe it'll be okay, maybe not.
Will the Rio Olympics be
a triumph of the human spirit,
or a giant human (bleep)?
We don't (bleep) know!
Anything right now!
Yeah, well, maybe
it could be okay.
You know,
with all this uncertainty,
it seems like the only rock
we have these days is The Rock,
-Dwayne Johnson.
-(cheers and applause)
He is our lifeboat!
Everything...
everything's gonna be okay
when The Rock's around.
Girls want to date him,
guys want to be him and also
want to date him. Last...
-(laughter and groaning)
-...Thursday,
he released a trailer announcing
his new YouTube channel.
What a great time to get in
on this YouTube craze-- 2016.
-(laughter)
-I always...
I always like to wait till
year 11 to get in on stuff.
This is how much
I love The Rock.
I just moved him into
my top eight on Myspace.
That's how much I love The Rock.
-(applause and cheering)
-Yeah.
Let's take a...
let's take a look
and feel how everything's okay.
MALE ANNOUNCER:
Once a generation
there comes an event so epic
that it dominates our culture.
♪
(laughter)
I should start
a YouTube channel.
Yeah, but first,
Rock's got to clear his, um...
-his browsing history.
-(laughter)
All right. Yeah. Fine, fine.
-(applause and cheering)
-Clear it.
That's how (bleep) cool
The Rock is.
He can make you excited
about a YouTube channel in 2016,
not to mention,
he even tossed us
a perfect joke set up alley-oop.
So, Comedians,
this is an interesting question.
What embarrassing items
might you find
in The Rock's browser history?
Mike Phirman, go.
He googled "Am I Vin Diesel?"
(laughter,
applause and cheering))
-Robin Thede.
-Can you still
get pubic lice
if you're totally shaved?
HARDWICK:
All right.
(laughter and groaning)
-Greg Proops. -Can you diagnose
what The Rock is growing?